c'est parti pour les concertations sur
la réforme des retraites première série
de consultations cet après-midi autour
du ministre du Travail Olivier du soft
l'objet de la réunion oui bien sûr je
vous entends
je vous entends mais a priori
vous m'entendez pas
une autre solution elle est simple c'est
12 milliards si on monte progressivement
les cotisations qui peuvent être
équitablement répartis entre l'employeur
et le salarié à hauteur de l'horizon
2030 de 30 euros on trouve 12 milliards
d'euros donc le cadre de la discussion
de cet après-midi c'était de fixer la
méthode de la
le cadre de la discussion aujourd'hui
c'était de les factures avec des prix
exorbitants des conditions de contrats
qui sont révisées de manière unilatérale
ces comportements abusifs de certains
fournisseurs dans la période actuelle
sont inacceptables et bien c'est
fournisseurs d'énergie on signé une
charte les engageant à protéger les
entreprises dans le contexte de hausse
de l'inflation et des prix de l'énergie
nous le voyons aucune raison pour que
des producteurs d'énergie profitent de
cette flambée de l’énergie pour se
constituer une rente sur la base de prix
de marché qui sont délirants pour éviter
la panne générale l'eau chaude pourrait
être partiellement coupée cet hiver
souriez vous êtes filmés chauffés vous
êtes contrôlés Big Brother s'appelle
Linky dès le 15 octobre via le compteur
Linky et NES coupera l'alimentation des
chauffe-eau en heures creuses entre midi
et 14h plus de 4 millions de foyers sont
concernés à Paris c'est une évidence le
est un échec le problème n'est pas
traité juste déplacé du 19e au 18e
arrondissement ou inversement alors
monsieur le ministre que comptez-vous
faire pour éradiquer définitivement le
trafic et la consommation du crack à
Paris évacuation ce matin d'un campement
d'usagers de crack dans le square force
va à Paris démantèlement définitifs
assurer le ministre de l'Intérieur
Gérald Darmanin à peu près un millier de
policiers étaient dans le 19e
arrondissement de Paris pour procéder à
la destruction après réquisition des
services de la Ville de Paris de
pourrait appeler ça une ville je mets
des guillemets j'étais vous savez pour
un amendement vis ma vie quand je suis
entré à l'Assemblée nationale c'est à
dire que le ministre de la justice il va
passer un moment en prison c'est pas une
allusion à l'actualité récente mais pour
voir comment ça se passe le ministre de
la Santé il va à l'hôpital pour voir
comment ça se passe et pour se mettre au
travail elle a dit avoir un ministre qui
va passer no suresque 24 heures dans ces
conditions là nous apprenons que le
garde des sceaux Eric Dupont-Moretti ici
présent et renvoyé devant la Cour de
Justice de la République pour des faits
commis pendant l'exercice de ce mandat
actuel comme ministre de la Justice et
rien pour la liberté et en solidarité
avec les femmes iraniennes Juliette
Binoche Isabelle Adjani Isabelle Huppert
Jeanne Birkin et Charlotte Gainsbourg ou
encore Angèle
elles sont 50
artistes les ciseaux à la main et elle
se coupe une mèche de cheveux où
était-elle où était ce milieu c'est pas
la première c'est pas d'aujourd'hui que
les femmes sont oppressées en Iran quand
l'actualité les pousse à intervenir et
bien sur le sur une logique émotionnelle
elles le font moi je préfère des
militantes de longue date des gens qui
s'engagent au quotidien plutôt que des
coups gardons-nous de jeter à nos
propres systématiques sur les serviteurs
de l'État sous prétexte qui ne
partageraient pas nos idées politiques
car vous savez que le nuage radioactif
qui découle de telles attaques va en
réalité irradier sur l'ensemble de la
classe politique et de l'ensemble des
serviteurs de l'Etat Sandrine Rousseau
c'est un peu comme un distributeur
automatique même quand on met pas un
euro dans la fente elle continue à
distribuer ses friandises vous avez raté
é